welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we break down all the
latest movies new game releases TV shows
and comic books
knives sau is slowly starting to make
its release worldwide and as the film
comes out in the UK today I thought it
was time to drop a breakdown that
discusses everything that you need to
know about the movie throughout this
video we'll be going over the movie's
big twist and discussing how it changes
the four elements of the film from the
start there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you haven't had a chance to watch
knives out yet and don't want to see
what's really going on in the donut
within a donut then I highly suggest
that you turn off now without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
our breakdown of knives out okay so
knives out centers around the death of
Harlan thrombi a successful crime
novelist that was found dead from an
apparent suicide after his 85th birthday
as with all deaths like this the police
have been called in to rule out any foul
play and joined by a criminal consultant
Benoit Blanc they slowly started unearth
the truth about what led to the
characters demise initially everyone in
the family is a suspect and each one of
them has a motive for killing Harlan
after he cut them out one by one from
his vast fortune meaning that they would
have to go off on their own to make
something of themselves from the off
knives ow is elevated above a lot of
crime mystery movies due to its amazing
cast that is really made up of some a
listers that relish playing the
duplicitous self-centered trust-fund
babies watching blanc interrogate them
as we learn what could have possibly
driven them to murder is amazing and
early on the film really sets up its key
players in an enthralling way that made
me feel instantly engaged with the movie
where knives out differs from your
typical whodunit though is that it
actually reveals what really happened in
the run-up to Holland's demise early on
and within the first half-hour we
discovered that the person apparently
behind it all was Holland's nurse martyr
martyr comes from a poor immigrant
family but due to her kind heart
Hollan has gained a lot of appreciation
for the young girl after the party Marta
and Harlan retired to his study to have
a game of Go and during it Holland
playfully tipped over the board when he
realized he was losing this knocked his
medication
as well and martyr mistakenly picked up
the wrong bottle and injected him with
100 milligrams of morphine unable to
find the antidote and with only 10
minutes left to live
Hollan gives martyrs strict instructions
on how she can leave the house
re-entered through a secret passage and
then make it so that it looked like
Harlan was still alive martyr carries
out this plan in Harlan slits his own
throat in front of her when she returns
to the house everything pretty much goes
according to plan though and it looks
like the girl is in the clear however a
mysterious benefactor has paid blonk to
investigate the crime and this is when
suspicion falls upon the family Marta is
seen as trustworthy though as every time
she lies she vomits and during the
reading of Harlan's will we discover
that he has left all of his possessions
to the character much to the family's
dismay everyone seems angered by this
except for Hugh ransom thrombi played
brilliantly by Chris Evans who already
knew that they were going to be cut out
of their father's fortune as Holland
told him at the party which caused him
to storm out and apparently have an
epiphany on the way home that it was the
right thing to do
ransom rescues Marta from the enrage
throm B's and at a restaurant she
confesses to him what really happened he
says that he will cover it up in
exchange for his cut of the fortune and
together the two form a team that try
and evade the eventuality of the
investigation all whilst the mysterious
blackmailer tries to threaten water with
Harlan's autopsy report it's a brilliant
setup and having a massive amount of the
mystery revealed early on is an inspired
choice I may not have been the biggest
fan of Rian Johnson after the last Jedi
and hey I may have even called him
ruined Johnson at some points however I
can't deny that he does a brilliant job
of creating his own well-developed
characters and twisting narrative that
has surprise after surprise in its
storyline what makes martes so engaging
is that you do genuinely believe that
she is a good person and it's easy to
put yourself in the characters shoes as
this was all just one big mistake that
got out of hand she's intimidated
threatened and manipulated by all
members of the family who try and
pressure her into giving back the
Fortuner every opportunity we learned
that the blackmail know is from one of
Holland's housekeepers known as Fran and
she leaves a time and place for the two
to meet through thick and thin martyr
manages to get to the low
and she finds Fran tied up and drugged
Marta and thaisa and Fran says you did
it before passing out marta calls for an
ambulance and in the car ride back to
the manor confesses what really happened
to blanc is it blank or is a blog a
sound are some really posh every time I
say Bronk let me know what you think in
the comments below everyone returns to
the home to see what Marta is going to
do about the inheritance but this is
stopped by Blanc who at the last minute
has realized what's going on now in
order to talk about the end of the film
I have to basically blow the big twist
wide open right now as it adds a lot of
context of the prior events and what
happens in the last act of the movie it
is revealed that ransom was in fact
behind the death of Holland and after
storming out of the party he snuck back
in using the secret entrance that Marta
did ransom took Marta's medical bag and
switched the labels on the medication
before removing the antidote so that the
character would inject him with the
fatal dose and have nothing to stop it
he then hired Blanc to investigate the
crime as he knew he would get to the
bottom of it and unearthed Marta as the
perpetrator of the characters death as
she was complicit in Holland's death
this would mean that her position in the
will would be null and void and thus all
of Holland's possessions will be split
amongst the family and ransom would get
his cut Holland's may discovered ransom
going through his room during the
funeral and this tried to blackmail him
which forced the character to kill her
when she said you did it
she actually said Hugh did it and no
martyr could have got away with it
she stayed to help Fran and thus ended
up confessing to Blanc what had really
went on now as we know that ransom
switched the balls it means that Martha
didn't give Hall in the lethal dose and
that his death was indeed a suicide this
means that Marta is in the clear and
though ransom didn't kill Holland either
he get arrested for the death of Fran I
have skipped over a couple of points
there in the movie most notably is scene
in which Marta tricks ransom into
believing that Fran is the lives that he
confesses to the plan thinking that he
won't be convicted for her death but I
just wanted to streamline the plot as
there are a lot of threads that could
have led to it being confusing there's
also a bit where it says that because
Marta is such a good nurse she
instinctively went for the correct
medication for Holland and therefore
wasn't complicit in his death
to ransom was the only one who knew that
he was out of the will ahead of time he
concocted this entire play in order to
get his share and honestly it's a twist
that I really didn't see coming
throughout movies like this I think we
are all guilty of trying to guess the
ending and Noah did have my suspicions
that the morphine may have been switched
around I really didn't see the twist
coming that it was ransom behind the
entire thing Marta vomits on ransom
after lying about the Fran thing and in
a fit of rage ransom tries to kill Marta
with a knife that turns out to be a prop
one that Holland mentioned earlier in
the movie in the end ransom is taken
away into custody past the shocked
family who all gather on the drive to
see what has happened Marta takes one of
Holland's cups that is labeled my house
my rules my coffee and she goes to the
balcony to overlook the pack of vultures
they all turn round and peer up at her
and she moves one of her fingers
covering the cup which reveals the top
line that says my house now the movie
cuts two credits after this and once we
don't get complete confirmation on
exactly what the character is going to
do with the fortune personally I believe
that she's too nice of a person and not
to give at least M or something
especially Meg who she bout to take care
of I would have loved to have seen her
tell them where to go but Marta is still
a nicest person in the movie maybe the
nicest person of all time
maybe the new sexy mother Teresa because
remember that bit in Blade Runner
come on there lads like the video it's
clear that she's keeping the house
though and after the tricks at the
thrombi is pulled I'd be surprised if
she didn't ask them from it too because
yeah let's face it they deserved it but
what did I think of the movie overall
well I really enjoyed knives out and it
shows that in Hollywood that can still
be original properties that make for
great movies all the actors at the
moment complaining the superhero films
have stopped there being a focus on
anything else need to take a good look
at knives out because it's a perfect
example of why they're wrong and when a
good idea is executed well it makes for
a really entertaining ride everything in
knives out just works really well and I
could have happily had another half hour
of the movie just following the family
and all the kinds of things that they
got up to you the cast really
complements the work and overall the
film is a brilliant deconstruction of
what a whodunit mystery is that
takes the classic elements apart and
celebrates them films like this are
pretty much either made or broken on
their twist and this did keep me
guessing throughout the movie which was
nice as doing a channel like this often
means that you pretty much watched the
same tropes over and over again knives
out feels like the perfect film to close
out the year and it's definitely worth
going to see in the cinema it feels like
a throwback to Poirot and the murder
mysteries of old that retains all of the
right elements whilst updating them for
modern audiences overall knives out is a
blast and it gets an 8.5 out of 10
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on knives now and what you
thought of the movie leave you a review
in the comment section below and if you
enjoyed this video then please give it a
thumbs up and don't forget to check out
our full breakdown of last week's
release 21 bridges which should be
linked at the end you go over everything
that you need to know about the film and
it's definitely worth checking out if
you have any questions about the movie
if you want to come chat to me after the
video then make sure you follow me on
twitter at definition whitey or head
over to my discord server which will be
linked in the description below we drop
videos on there early so if you want to
see stuff before anyone else then that's
the best place to be it's free at
joining we have an awesome community so
hopefully I'll see you over there very
soon we'll see giving away a free copy
of the Marvel phase 3 part 2 boxer on
blu-ray which contains Black Panther
infinity war and Game Captain Marvel and
more and all you have to do to be in
with the chance of winning is like the
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts or
knives out in the comment section below
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of December and the cell be
shipped out from the end to ever gets
the prize it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
you
[Music]